Film Courage: Why is it so
difficult to make a great movie?
R. Ellis Frazier, Director, Producer, CEO at
BADHOUSE Studios: There's just so many moving
parts to make a great movie and you look at films
like Apocalypse Now Godfather the the real the
real great movies Forrest Gump and there's so
many moving parts and so many people have to
believe in the project from the financiers,
to the actors, to the distributors to the
people that are making the adjustments on the
script and things of that sort. You really have
to get lucky frankly let's be real on having
all those things to come together because it's
not just the money it's not just the money it's
and it's not just the big actor it's got to be
the whole thing I look at films like Forrest Gump
and that's just a truly brilliant piece expansive
and meaningful it makes you cry it makes you laugh
and it means something and then you look at films
like Godfather series Apocalypse Now, all those
truly great films (Taxi Driver) and I think that
it's just you got to get lucky in so many ways
and it's just timing and you just do your best
you're trying to make a great film every time
you're trying to no matter how small you're
trying to do that's the beauty of it right you're
trying to everybody's trying to make a great film
the greatest film everyone does it come out to be
the greatest film but we're all trying and some of
them get there and some of them don't so you when
you hit that lucky stride of creativity and the
right amount of resources and money and the right
amount of right amount of talent behind everything
and then just the right synergy and energy then
it turns into something magic but it at the end
of the day it has to start with the story and you
have to have the story in a way that people can
get behind it and give it the chance to be that
greatness so it's just got a lot of different ways
to skin that cat but very few cats get skinned in
that way so so it's that's why they're so special
when we see them that's why we watch them a
thousand times that's why we they get all the love
and adoration that they do well if we watch is it
Hearts of Darkness [A Filmmaker's Apocalypse] or
Heart of Darkness so we see that Coppola did not
there was luck was not really on his side for much
of the film even though it turned out incredible
so he had many things well Harvey Keitel was the
actor and they fired him Martin Sheen had a heart
attack they ran out of money several times Marlon
Brando wasn't being cooperative it was it people
it was it was a it was a huge mess there were
government issues they right and they and they
have a whole if you see the redux it's the whole
section of the film wasn't even there but there
was a thread in that film that is the same thread
as on the river that said that pulled the the boat
up the river to the and that never and there's
a line there it says never get off the boat and
it's very interesting because that ultimately is
about the story never get off the boat there's too
much stuff going on the boat regardless of all the
chaos and they did a great job of showing when
they got off the boat how much chaos there was
stay on the boat stay on the river and then that
lead you to the end chaos but there's at least
some kind of closure here so my feeling is that
Hearts of Darkness I saw it I was like a lot of
people would have given up a lot of people and he
didn't he stayed on the boat and got to the end
and for that it's brilliant and he also cooked it
up in the edit let's say you were going to write a
warrior filmmakers Manifesto what would be some
of the core tenants I don't know I think I have
some written here but just sort of like don't use
a tool that you you don't know much about or don't
become overly attached to one particular method
yeah that's okay well me personally and it's been
a theme throughout the thing is that don't don't
control everything let people do their work don't
try to be you have to trust the process and trust
that everything is going to turn out okay and that
trust is contagious throughout the set and when
you have that you're set as a lot of has harmony
second independent filmmakers you have to cut out
cancers and poisons quickly you can't let them
fester inside of production if you have people
that are being toxic if you have people that are
are disruptive you we must get them out of there
as soon as possible because we don't have the time
or money to have we're in one war here we can't
have many wars within the war get rid of it as
soon as possible and get rid of it so everybody
understands that this will not be tolerated it's
very important in indie film because films can
become a big mess and one of the things that's
so interesting that I've seen is that a lot of
films and I don't know if I should mention that
one film we talked about but but I just looked
at that like that's like on every set it doesn't
matter $50,000 movie they all it's just they have
six seven million do and they still have the same
problems as the $660,000 movie so it's not about
the money it's about the management of of the of
the project and the team and when you have a lot
of really bad elements or potentially bad elements
in that thing in in in your film you have to get
them out quick don't let them fester get it out of
there that's what that's the if you're going to
be a prod producer you got to know that and you
have to be able to know where that's coming from
okay so that would be the manifesto yeah I have
to think about a Manifesto Warriors Manifesto
I have to think about like some of those things
that would that would be but I it probably yeah
just just keep your set harmony is everything and
that's how you get what you want you have to keep
keep you have to concentrate on set harmony if you
if you don't have set harmony you're not going
to get what you want and you're probably going
to go over a budget and you're probably going to
not have the the artistic outcomes that you're
looking for so keep your set calm and working well
and let people do the work that they're they're
doing without being too heavy-handed and Trust
the process just to play The Devil's Advocate
for a moment so I think if you are working with
the same crew then this person's strong in this
area and vice over here this person's great at
this but if it's a new set coming together there
would be some problems so how can someone stop a
train wreck from happening when when sometimes so
many moving parts and egos I don't know if it's
possible that people are going to have their own
agendas it's not possible and it's one of the
reasons that you should strive as a filmmaker
to find your crew get a crew find even if it's
they're coming from everywhere but find that
one sound guy find the one art department people
your film journey should be a good portion of it
not just creation of a product but building a team
so that the creation of the product becomes more
efficient so you can't you you can't you have to
just do the trial and error you're going to find
people and you just try to get as good people as
possible with good and really do vetting if you
can but at the end of the day you're going to
run into that and so you just have to live and
learn and learn to keep things keep things moving
and get a really good line producer that's strong
and willing to get rid of toxic elements poison
elements quickly so that they don't fester so you
can keep moving forward but at the end of the
day you want to get that's the whole point you
want to have your own crew you want to you want
to be able to have a team of people that will let
you have a shorthand with and that you don't
have to worry about you don't have to explain
everything to them from scratch if something
happens they give you the benefit of the doubt
instead of thinking that somehow you're coming
from a bad place so when you build that's what
that 10 years is for or whatever is to build up a
a team of people that you can trust and depend on.